with the uproar over his first summit
with Russia's leaders still
reverberating throughout the halls of
political Washington we learned tonight
President Trump has already told his
staff to work on a sequel and the
president is again blaming the messenger
the media for obstructing his message
about the original meeting correspondent
Kevin cork starts us off tonight from
the North Lawn of the White House Gregg
good evening the White House would
certainly be loved to describe this as a
do-over instead they're calling this a
continuation of an important
conversation as we learn late this
afternoon by way of Twitter from Sarah
Sanders the White House press secretary
Russian President Vladimir Putin could
be on his way to Washington as soon as
this fall the tweet came late this
afternoon White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders writing that the president
had asked his national security adviser
John Bolton to invite Russian President
Vladimir Putin to Washington in the fall
which Sanders adding that the
discussions were already underway but
that apparently came as a bit of news to
a key member of the president's national
security cadre were you aware of that
just want to clarify I think I'm based
on my reaction I wasn't aware of that
okay but the news did little to blunt
criticism of the president's handling of
the Helsinki summit and his seeming
vacillation over whether or not he
believes Russia is still targeting US
elections with cyber warfare and that
seemed to frustrate the president who in
a hail of tweets this morning placed
blame for the negative narrative on
so-called
fake news media repeatedly chiding them
for suggesting he simply wasn't tough
enough on Russia tweeting that he'd
recognized Russian meddling many times
call it the Putin summit a great success
adding I look forward to our second
meeting the president's declaration
coming just hours after a detailed
report in The New York Times that
suggested two weeks before his
inauguration mr. Trump was briefed by
CIA director John Brennan Director of
National Intelligence James clapper and
NSA director Admiral Mike Rogers and a
report that showed mr. Trump highly
classified intelligence indicating that
Vladimir Putin himself ordered cyber
attacks to sway the 2016 election in an
interview with CNBC this afternoon the
president said he'd already been tougher
on Russia than any president
in many many years and that would
continue if things didn't improve
between our two countries if that
doesn't work out I'll be the worst enemy
he's ever had the worst he's ever had in
signing an executive order to encourage
investment and new training for American
workers to better prepare them for jobs
of tomorrow and today President Trump
this afternoon tried to shift the
nation's focus back toward his domestic
agenda to keep this momentum going to
continue this economic miracle and
that's what it is it's a miracle what's
happened in the last year and a half we
must invest in job training and
vocational education unveiling the
National Council for the American worker
the administration said its plan will
create hundreds of thousands if not
millions of new jobs over the next five
years Brett for context we can tell you
that the last time Vladimir Putin came
here to the White House was all the way
back in 2005 last time a Russian
president came here 2010 Dmitry Medvedev
made his way here it's been a long time
no matter how you look at it Brett Kevin
quark live in the North Lawn Kevin
thanks